this former billionaire lost about 80
percent of his wealth in record time he
went from being worth 1.9 billion
dollars to just 400 million dollars in
just a few weeks
by violating a crucial law of power
always say less than necessary he
bragged openly that none of the big
Brands he had business deals with would
dare to stop working with him he was
trash-talking Jews he even called
himself a Nazi he thought he was
invincible but then everything collapsed
in a matter of weeks Adidas Balenciaga
gapped they all canceled their business
deals with him JP Morgan reportedly
unbanked him his agency dropped him and
just like that a billion dollar Fortune
disappeared practically overnight and
who is this madman Kanye West click the
link in the pinned comment to learn how
the world really works